[Music]
take to mark
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so let me get this right we're forced to
listen to this spa music so your head
doesn't explode and kill us all
[Music]
whoa Clarion
in my head I saw that differently
Pokemon detective Pikachu only in
theaters May 10th rated PG so there I
was woke up with a heavy case of amnesia
in the middle of nowhere
the only clue to my past is Harry's name
and an address inside this hat so I made
my way to be partnered and that's what I
found you make your stapler gonna loosen
so you're a talky Pikachu with no
memories who's addicted to caffeine I
could stop whatever I want these are
just choices another round extra shot I
don't know maybe hair got in too deep
and mixed up the wrong crowd that kind
of thing you can talk to humans I can
talk to Pokemon
and if you want to find your pops we're
gonna need no I don't need a Pokemon
what about a world-class detective Harry
is still alive
case closed but still open until I solve
it all right here it is
Harry faked his own death or somebody
else faked Terry's death
[Music]
or Harry take somebody else's death that
last one doesn't work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now obviously I've dealt with this putz
before so I'll just do it again hey bud
what are you doing I can't do when
people are watching
[Music]
that's a twist that's very twisty
no he's barely moving don't tell him
that
oh he's on a bike quick get in front of
him stop oh no he's going down hard Tim
should have worn a helmet
[Music]